TO FINISH OFF THIS NOW FOREVER
SCARRED SEMESTER.
BRET?
>> Bret: THANKS.
NOW BACK TO CPAC IN SUBURBAN
WASHINGTON.
CONSERVATIVES GATHERED ACROSS
THE POTOMAC IN MARYLAND.
THEY'RE NOT ONLY LISTENING TO
SOME OF THEIR IDEOLOGICAL
LEADERS, THEY'RE GETTING
HANDS-ON TRAINING IN ACTIVISM.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOSEY
REPORTS ON GRASSROOTS TRAINING.
>> REPUBLICANS KNOW THEY HAVE A
MAMMOTH MIDTERM CHALLENGE AHEAD
BECAUSE 2018 IS A DO-OVER FOR
DEMOCRATS.
>> WE HAVE SEEN ENERGY ON THE
DEMOCRATS SIDE.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO
ANOINT US IN 2016.
THEY'RE READY TO COME AT THE
MIDTERMS AND HOPEFULLY TAKE BACK
THE MAJORITY.
WE HAVE TO BE JUST AS ENERGIZED.
I EXPECT A TURNOUT IN A LOT OF
STATES.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS PREDICTING
A PROBLEM FOR HIS PARTY.
>> SO PEOPLE ARE SITTING THERE
AND THEY'RE SAYING, WE JUST HAD
-- LET'S NOT VOTE.
LET'S GO TO A MOVIE.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, WE'RE
GOING TO DO GREAT AND THEN THEY
END UP LOSING.
SO YOU GOT TO KEEP UP THE
ENTHUSIASM.
>> SO CPAC HOSTED AN ACTIVISTS
BOOT CAMP TO SHARE STRATEGY.
SENATE HOPEFULS ARE REFINING
THEIR PITCHES TO KEEP
REPUBLICANS INTERESTED.
MICHIGAN'S JOHN JAMES, VETERAN
AND BUSINESSMAN THINKS CASTING A
WIDE NET WILL HELP HIM UNSEAT A
SENATOR.
>> FOR SUPPORT AND PROTECT THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AGAINST ALL ENEMIES
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC AND THAT
REQUIRES FIRING UP OUR BASE
WITHOUT ALIENATING TRADITIONAL
REPUBLICANS AND MAKE SURE WE
HOLD DEMOCRATS IN THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
MISDEEDS AND NEGLECT.
>> ARIZONA'S DR. KELLY WARD
RUNNING TO REPLACE SENATOR JEFF
FLAKE MANS TO HIGHLIGHT HER
STATUS AS AN OUTSIDER.
>> WE AS REPUBLICANS HAVE TO
GIVE OUR ELECTORATE CANDIDATES
THAT INSPIRE THEM TO GO TO THE
POLLS.
>> AND OHIO BUSINESSMAN MIKE
GIBBONS HOPING TO UNSEAT SENATOR
SHARED BROWN PLANS TO MAKE HIS
CAMPAIGN A TRIBUTE TO TRUMP.
>> I LIVE IN CLEVELAND, OHIO,
WHERE TRUMP DIDN'T DO TOO WELL.
THROW A ROCK OUT OF WINDOW IN
CLEVELAND, CHANCES IS YOU'LL HIT
A DEMOCRAT.
THE REST OF THE STATE DOES NOT
FEEL THAT WAY.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD WIN OHIO BY A
BIGGER MARGIN THAN HE TOOK THE
LAST ONE.
>> SO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RECORD
IS THE THING THAT CONSERVATIVE
CANDIDATES THINK WILL CARRY THEM
ALL THE WAY TO WASHINGTON.
AND THERE IS NOT MUCH TALK ABOUT
THE GROUP ABOUT THINGS THEY WISH
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD BE DOING
DIFFERENTLY OR SHOULD BE DOING
DIFFERENTLY TO HELP THEIR
CHANCES MORE.
INSTEAD, THESE CANDIDATES SEEM
CONTENT THAT WHAT THE PRESIDENT